[Music]  we continue to keep babylon safe from  the deviants more people have come to  seek refuge  it is now the largest city on earth the  eternal serving the missions across the  galaxies will learn from you and  something unusual is happening to earth  it is a side effect of the emergence  [Music]  the emergence to begin  our universe is a constant exchange of  energy  an infinite cycle of creation and  destruction  she has helped many celestials to emerge  over millions of years  gathered from host planets to create  suns  generate heat and light  for new galaxies to form  face as the prime eternal  do not fail me  so  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you for judgment